thanks christine and with a draw by
irina crush she's now a full point ahead
of
second place with the game pending
caterina sova they're certainly in the
mix
we saw you lose a bad game earlier in
the tournament now you've won three in a
row you've defeated three former
champions in the same tournament things
could not be going any better for you
what's been the secret
i mean
i don't really know like i said earlier
maybe a couple rounds ago
like my friends were telling me i needed
to relax a bit get out of my head
and i think that's really helped me play
like
better chess so
yeah we see you pressing your opponents
on the clock is that intentional or it's
just you see the move you want to play
it
um kind of a little bit of both i feel
like everyone gets a like a lot more
anxious when they're
way behind on the clock and
usually for me i always find that like
my first instinct is usually a pretty
good move so
yeah
your style seems pretty direct
threatened here threatening here
threatening here figure out these moves
what contributes to that stock because
you're not seem to be doing deep
positional maneuvers it's all about
putting the threats on them and seeing
whether they can solve what to do
yeah i mean i feel like it's all about
like putting pressure on your opponent
anna
they always kind of eventually
crack if you do it right
so yeah
this game the opening seemed to go very
well for you play queen a5 check
preparation
uh yeah it was like a little bit of
preparation from actually last year's
championship against uh
anna zatonski
so i had that line prepared in advance
and i saw that
sabina had played had like sort of
allowed for this position in her game
against irena
so i didn't really look too closely
into it because it kind of requires like
a very specific set of moves from white
uh
but i kind of knew like the general idea
and i knew that like night knight d2 is
not really the best because then i kind
of get like a nice accelerated dragon
style position
with
her knight being misplaced on d2 instead
of c3
yeah you got that position very very
quickly
when did you feel confident i know you
got a chance to play knight h5 knight
takes f4 and it seemed like things were
going in your direction
yeah i mean i feel like after i got
the bishop hair and like ruined her king
side structure a little bit i just felt
generally pretty good about my position
i felt like
like my style sort of just usually
putting pressure on my opponents right
like we've mentioned so
so i thought this was like
very easy for me to play as opposed to
her having to find like all the right
moves to keep the balance
you've won very powerfully in every game
uh this one was again direct and and
strong what's it gonna take for you
you're into a rest day what's the
mindset needed now to close this thing
out
i mean i kind of just want to
keep like the same mindset like i said
every time i get stressed i just play
worse so
just want to focus on playing playing
good chess
all right congrats on your performance
so far good luck the rest of the way
thank you carissa i did have a question
for you because
the move that you played
queen e6 exactly in this position
turned out to be a really strong move
and everything worked
marvelously from from that point
forwards and yet for me the move queen
e6
was a difficult move to find i would i
would have resisted playing that move in
fact the move i i was absolutely
at least i had convinced myself you were
going to do was trying you know you
played rook c5 to do a rook up and over
and i was pretty sure
you were going to play e6 which is not
that great a move its advantage for you
still how did you come
in this position to the
to the
to to make the move queen e6 which like
i said is a very good move how did that
your queen look so good on h3 you gave
it you you moved it away
yeah i mean
first of all i felt like she was kind of
throwning queen d3 anyway so my queen
would have to be forced back
okay and
um
and i kind of already started like
trying to play on the queen side a
little bit with my b5 push
um
and if she doesn't exchange off the
rooks
exactly one move late uh
whoops i apologize i came exactly just a
little bit later so you actually came up
with queen e6 and again you gave up the
h3 square sorry
please go ahead continue with what you
were saying oh yeah i was just saying
i was trying to start like some queen
side plan i thought my queen would
probably be
better positioned on e6 okay and um like
e4 kind of is a little bit of a weakness
for her i felt like
so
yeah i mean my queen was going to get
kicked off h3 anyway so i thought i
would just do it on my own terms if i'm
gonna ask you one last question were you
annoyed
in any way that she didn't resign
earlier when players are playing in that
kind of lost position or you just feel
like they're playing i don't care
no i mean i still felt like i had some
some accurate moves left to make until
the end of the game so
it was pretty reasonable i thought to
wait until then yeah all right well
again congratulations get your rest
we'll see you in two days thank you
absolutely chris well done very very
impressive